you're over here it's great it was just
like
we got some mortal kombat tv spots to
watch here
this video is called scorpion meets
sub-zero i believe they got a couple of
tv spots combined based off of the
beautiful people who send me
links and i go oh this is the one thanks
for the info so of course we'll react to
this and then you know
talk about it afterwards we're getting
some interviews lately i'm trying to get
one with the director right now
be cool and one with scorpion and
sub-zero specifically if we could try to
get that
boom if we could get them over here
see what i did there see what i did
there
let's watch it
[Music]
listen carefully watch
learn mortal kombat has begun
it has begun
you
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
back damn combat who's first
whoo
what is that oh there's another one
history different cultures
it's three
[Music]
[Music]
man you have more kung lao action
yo what is he wearing
what there's this over here it keeps on
giving
[Music]
what is the outfit he's wearing
[Music]
we'll be right back with some
screenshots
see who those people are i'm loving it
so we got screenshots of a couple
moments
here but first off i gotta say ryden
looks great yes ryden fantastic
dan looks
incorrect pronunciation i just i just
commit to my mispronunciations
it's raiden the
other moments are you getting some cool
kung lao shots i'm loving the way kung
lao is looking lovely king obviously
so this is looking cool but then you got
a couple of shots here that really stand
out to me this one right here
obviously that's molina you get a lot
more molina in these tv spots which i'm
happy to see
even see her fighting uh sonya blade in
the trailer
the girls have to fight each other yes
this is the rules the way it goes
it looks like on the left here you got
reiko on the right side that is
kabal yeah i think this is raco because
there was something that came out about
nathan jones playing raco
in mortal kombat and that looks like
that design when those photos came
out so i'm pretty sure that's who it is
and then this other moment here that
really stood out was sonya blade
shooting her firearm
in self-defense
that looks like it could be reptile
i'm venturing i guess i mean if you
really slow it down you can catch a
tongue and some teeth in there and what
looks like yeah like a reptile jaw
able to cloak himself i think in the
official trailer though didn't they
spoil the fate of reptile in that actual
trailer well it looked like uh cato
takes him out in the in the trailer
right that's what it was certainly
seemed like anyway unless right
there yeah as it stands very excited for
this movie i think it's going to be
great
you know what's funny about this whole
cole young thing uh
it's something that a lot of fans are
not very excited about just because it's
like a new character
and like we got all these other main
characters and oftentimes if we're going
to do something like a cole
young that usually doesn't go well i
have my theories about
what could be going on with him talked
about in the mortal kombat official
trailer
uh especially after watching like
scorpion's revenge getting myself
updated on some lore that i missed out
on with mortal kombat i feel like
that he is somehow linked to scorpion
based off of
the footage that we've seen even kind of
like the costume that cole young is even
wearing here that he might be linked to
the shirai ryu clan
uh that scorpion is from perhaps blood
related in some way because you do see
him in that fight with scorpion and
sub-zero and it looks like
scorpion will have more of the anti-hero
position
versus a villainous position which
sub-zero is clearly
inhabiting all that aside what's getting
me excited for cole young is strictly
lewis tan himself i follow him on social
media
you just gotta follow him the enthusiasm
that he shares
all the support of representation as
well
the passion that he has on display he
has sold
me on getting excited not i'm already
excited for the movie
but now i'm really looking forward to
seeing what he does with this because
clearly
he cares a lot he's very passionate
he was very much involved because of
lewis tan
i'm more excited about what the
possibilities of what colion could be in
terms of like the performance because
obviously he's not going to half asses
in any way
and he has i believe he's the one who
had the standout scene in iron fist
season one
the only one who had a good scene i
think it was
dragon boxes it's a high phase mark good
thing too that i hope for is along with
that enthusiasm that this might be an
opportunity for them to
take a trope type character that is
telltale of not so great movies of this
variety from the past and then
re-contextualize it and maybe
twist it into something that yeah
becomes more meaningful as the movie
goes on and then can surprise us all
with something that's neat
or that maybe splits the difference or
something like that and and yeah i could
definitely
imagine him being linked to scorpion
especially again just because
so much of his costuming is also yellow
i do hope especially given you know like
what you said about lewis tan that
people do
respond to that character because you
know i mean at the end of the day it
still just depends on how the movie
itself comes across
yeah even in this trailer it's like no
he's the lead oh yeah
i mean it looks it certainly looks like
from those scorpion sub-zero fight
shots where he's like freezing the bars
and they're in that place that looks all
frozen over like it's probably just the
three of them in some kind of climactic
personal battles right right all right
guys with mortal kombat you excited for
it got your hbo max subscription now the
theaters are opening up more and more
are you going to go watch it in the
theaters let us know subscribe click
that notification bell hit that like
button last but not least
jean jeter genie i gotta say bud
you've got a video out for march here it
is called
isolation hostile here's the thumbnail
go watch it watch it just go watch it
it's a pleasant video to say the least
it's a really fascinating fascinating
mirror it's a little bit surreal you
might say
yes there are two sides to the story to
uncover
there's a there's a good-looking person
there's a good-looking person
gene thank you so much for supporting us
and uh for making these awesome videos
i'll make sure to follow this person
through john's social media that's right
gina
if you ever get any activity for me
in fact i've never seen any of your
stuff to be honest
[Music]